But the father is above the son. The son
sorry.
What sense is he above the son?
Um in authority.
Okay.
What about the Holy Spirit?
Uh so I would say that is the spirit of
the father. And what does that mean he's
the spirit of the father? It's the
father's spirit, his presence. His
presence, okay. Okay, so
if you
one thing that
Avery likes to do, he always keeps
uh screen sharing and he takes it off
the screen because he wants me to lose
my testimony and I could I want you I
want your face on, man. They need to see
your face. Come on.
to bring it to You want to bring it up?
I'll I'll bring it up for you. Even
though we're back to the Bible, not the
church fathers, that's fine. I I'll I'll
jump. So the spirit is the presence of
the father, right? That's what you said.
Yeah. All right. Well, it's the father's
spirit.
That's what you just said. The spirit is
the father's presence, the presence of
the father, exactly, right?
Sure. Yeah, we can go there.
Okay. Uh just please, if you want to
have a real serious conversation, we'll
try to answer your questions answered
directly, not the tap dance. I'm not
saying you will, but the others did.
John 16:12-13. I still have many more
things to say to you. You cannot bear
them now, but when he, the spirit of
truth, comes
he'll guide you in all truth, for he'll
not speak from himself. Whatever he
hears, he will speak. He He hears from
whom?
He hears from the father because he's
coming from the father. Yeah, but he's
the presence of the father. So you're
saying this presence is a person?
So if you want to look at it that way,
sure. I don't have a
care about how I want to look at it. I
want you to deal with the text cuz it
says, listen to what he's saying. He'll
only speak what he hears. Who's he
hearing from?
Well, again, he's hearing from the
father. So I hold on. I'm also trying to
pull it up in my as well. So I'm
listening to you.
Okay, but that's the point. So if he's
hearing, that's something persons do,
not just simply forces. So you're not
saying the spirit is a force, right?
I didn't necessarily say it was a force.
I'm saying that it's the father's
spirit. Now, it can be because we're
humans and we're finite, it could appear
to us as a force. But let's say you're
praying Yeah, I'm not talking about how
the person is.
I would appreciate
if you just deal with the text of
scripture. You didn't answer the
question.
You didn't answer the question. You went
into a false analogy. So I'm going to
ask it again.
If he's a presence that hears and
speaks, so you're saying that this is a
person?
Sure. I'm I'm not having issue with
that. So is this person uncreated or
created?
He comes from the father. So saying that
that he's created He's not created.
or created? No, he wouldn't be created
like a human, no. So now I just want you
to hear yourself. This is recorded. You
said the father
and the spirit comes from the father.
The spirit hears from the father.
So he's hearing from someone and the
spirit is a person uncreated. Do the
math for me. How many is that?
Uh that would be three individuals if
you're looking at it from that
perspective, sure.
No, I didn't include Jesus here. Let's
stick with the father and the spirit. Do
the math for me. So how many is that?
Okay, so again, so that again, that's
two. That's not a problem for me.
And they're both uncreated, right? Yeah,
that's not a problem for me.
Okay, good. So now you're now one step
closer to the Trinity because you admit
they're uncreated, which I like. No,
that No, so
Yes, they're uncreated. Well, hold on.
Let me let me explain my view first.
My view does not require the the son or
the rock to be created.
That's perfectly fine if they're
uncreated.
So they're all uncreated?
Yeah, that's not a requirement. Because
if if the father Let me just explain. If
the father All right. If the son comes
from the father, that's very different
than being created like we are. If the
spirit is coming from the father, that's
very different than being created like
we are. In that sense, they all can be
eternal, but the father is still
created.
you're qualifying it. You did the tap
dance. I didn't ask you whether they're
created like we are. I'm going to repeat
my question again.
If they come out of the father, then
you're saying they have no beginning cuz
they're in the father and whatever's in
the father is not created, right? They
are uncreated, yes. Okay, so then stop
saying created like us. I don't get the
analogy. So
How else would they be created?
Say it again? How else would they be
created?
So are they created now?
No, I'm asking you this. You said
created like us. Stop saying that. I'm
asking you this how other kind of
creation could they be?
Because we are created from matter that
was brought into being from nothing. But
you are telling me son and spirit are
from the father, so they were within the
father, whatever that means in your
world view, and nothing in the father is
created, so they're all uncreated,
right?
Okay, sure. Again, that's fine.
I'm not sure. Do you believe they're
uncreated?
Yes, I said that multiple times. Okay.
How many How many do you have that are
uncreated now?
One cuz you have the father. No, because
you have the son and spirit. No, no, you
said son and spirit.
You said son and spirit uncreated. Do
the math for me.
Right.
How many is that?
You can say I'll let you
I'll let you speak for a second. Yeah.
So So
in terms of what y'all are talking
about, I think what he has is trying to
establish is his view of what this is
called in terms of the Trinity. Like we
hold the defense that
the the son,
who everyone calls Jesus, who we call
Yeshua, he is not the most high.
And we'll get there. We'll get there in
a second. We just want to establish
they're uncreated, right? That's in
terms of That's in terms of his uh I
would say our view. Now, in terms of the
the creation of the uncreation aspect,
uh the father himself is uncreated. Now,
in terms of for us, we are created. We
come from something. Uh what does it
say? Elohim formed man from the dust of
the earth. So there is a specific
substance in which we are created from.
Now, in terms of the son and in terms of
the spirit, they have the exact same
spirit as the father.
Yeah, you're making no sense, buddy. So
when I let you speak so I don't people
think say I'm cutting you off because I
want them to hear you you guys don't
answer anything. I'm sitting here
because I don't want to be accused of
cutting you off. I'm going to try it
again.
I know you gave a long speech and yeah,
yeah, we're going to try it again.
Do you affirm
You already did. I just said that we
believe they're uncreated. Yes, do you
believe son and spirit are uncreated,
they have no beginning?
I could have swore I said yes to this
like five times.
No, but
Take it easy, man. We're talking to the
other guy, right? You had him chime in
and then do your dirty work. Take it
easy.
Your buddy here, your partner in crime,
cuz I don't want to get into the most
high aspect. Do you agree son and spirit
are uncreated, have no beginning?
I would say that the say
the son
came before what we know as
creation.
They can't answer questions directly and
you're contradicting your friend by
that. That's why I want to put you guys
against each other.
I want to make it again clear.
Is the son uncreated, has no beginning?
Forget about you and me. Is he
uncreated, has no beginning? He has no
beginning. Okay, so he's uncreated. All
right. Go ahead. Okay. Is the spirit
uncreated, has no beginning? Yes. Okay,
now follow me cuz we're going to go into
the text now with the most high.
Is the son the same as the spirit?
In terms of what?
The spirit of the father that he just
told us he was presence of the father,
whom Jesus was going to send. Is that
spirit Jesus?
No. Okay. So the son and spirit, they're
not the same person. They're both
uncreated, right? Mhm. Count them out.
How many is that?
Two.
And then you said the father is
uncreated, right? Mhm.
And he's not the son, right? No.
And he's not the spirit. No. So you just
admitted there are three uncreated
persons.
You could say there are three uncreated
gods.
Even though when I show you the
scripture
If you want If you want If you want to
say that, well, technically it'd be two
uncreated gods because the spirit itself
is not actually called God. Yes, he is.
Second Samuel 23:2-3. I'll get there.
Just What What What What verse again?
We'll get there. Second Samuel 23:2-3.
You said Samuel 23?
Two to three, yeah. We'll bring it up on
the screen, guys.
Second Samuel chapters two and three.
Guys, guys, we'll we'll get there in a
second. Just be patient.
So the spirit is uncreated,
but he speaks to the father, the father
speaks to him. According to the Hebrew
scriptures,
how many uncreated gods are there?
One.
Mhm. You just said, I want everyone to
hear this, the spirit
speaks to the Your partner did anyway. I
don't know if you're going to deny it.
The spirit
hears from the father
and he only speaks what the father tells
him. So that means he's a person who's
uncreated, but there's only one god
who's uncreated.
So then if the spirit is uncreated and
he's not the father, but he's a person,
what kind of god would that make him?
Can you ask Can you ask that question
again? I was looking something up. Ask
Can you ask that again for me? Second
Samuel You're excited with Second Samuel
23. We'll get there.
Your buddy here just admit
that there's only one uncreated god. One
god uncreated.
Okay. But then you both agreed the
spirit is uncreated
and he's a person.
So then what would that make him? Not a
god? A false god?
Because you said there's only one
uncreated god. So now you're adding a
second uncreated god?
So what would that make the spirit?
The spirit comes from the father.
Okay. So if you're at if your question
saying the one true god then, right?
Sure, if you want to look at it that
way. Again,
why why
they contradict you? Why'd your buddy
contradict?
Your buddy over here Yes, he did. I'm
going to repeat what he said. It's
recorded. He goes, you can say there are
two gods
and the spirit still are called a god
even if he's not called god. You just
agreed that the spirit cuz he comes from
the father, yeah, you can call him the
true god. So
who should I now refute? You or your
friend cuz you're now arguing against
each other. Well, we're not arguing
Yeah, you didn't show where the spirit
is called god. Yeah, we're not arguing
against each other. I guess you're not
listening. Okay, I'm going to show you
buddy.
You Even if I don't show you, you just
admit he has to be the true god because
let me repeat it again.
I asked you how many
No, no, he does not have to be the true
god if he comes from the true god.
So but he's a person that speaks to the
true god. So then what is he?
Okay, a prophet speaks to the true god.
What is he? Oh, but the prophet is
uncreated?
The prophet is created. It doesn't It
doesn't matter. What we're saying
Spirit is created? What we're saying
What we're saying is
Spirit is created? The spirit comes from
the father.
Is he created?
He's uncreated. Okay. How many gods are
there
that are uncreated?
You have the one true the most high.
And that most high
is uncreated, right? Yes. And the spirit
is uncreated?
If the spirit comes from the father.
That's not my question. I know you're
talking to tap dancers. And the spirit
is uncreated? We're not tap dancing. You
keep asking the same question over and
over.
Yeah, because I'm going to show you
The spirit is uncreated? No, we're not
switching.
The spirit is uncreated? The spirit is
uncreated. Okay, so then that means he's
the most low?
Because you just said the most high is
uncreated. So if the spirit is
uncreated, so now he's the most low?
How many most highs are there that are
uncreated?
There's one most high. So there's only
one most high that's uncreated, right?
But the son is not the most high and the
holy spirit is not the most high. They
come from the most high. Okay. You're
scared you're doing a marathon.
Listen to me cuz we're going to go in
scripture. Okay. So So there's Go to the
scripture. Go to the text where it shows
that. Is there only one most high that's
uncreated? Go to the text where it shows
that.
to ask you someone to get you out of
here if you don't answer.
Okay.
There's only one most high that's
uncreated? Yes. Okay.
Only one most high that's uncreated.
Mhm. Is there anyone else besides the
most high that's uncreated? No.
You just heard the holy spirit has to be
the most high cuz you said he's
uncreated. That is a terrible argument.
So I know you got buried. Yeah, you
didn't get You didn't bury me with
anything. Hold on. Wait a minute. Wait a
minute. Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Can you just show one place? You
mentioned 2 Samuel.
I'm going to show you
10,000 places. You ready?
You ready?
I'm going to show you. Just take it
easy, buddy. Well, I'm not like you
guys. I'm going to show you scripture.
Just take it easy, buddy. Guys clipped
us too. They just Hold on. How How
How you going to Okay, go ahead. Go
ahead. Why you take it easy, brother?
Man, we're brothers.
Okay. Go ahead. Um go ahead. Okay, hold
on. I am going ahead if you just wait.
I'm going to get 2 Samuel, buddy.
Jeremiah 31:33-34.
But this is the covenant which I will
cut with the house of Israel after those
days, declares Yahweh, right? So this
Yahweh, right?
It's not Yahusha, right?
We say We say
We say Yahuah, but Yahweh's fine. Yeah,
you can say that.
Okay, Yahuah. I will put my law within
them and on their heart I will write it.
And I will be their god and they shall
be my people.
And they will not teach again each man
his neighbor and each man his brother
saying, "Know Yahuah."
So it's not Yahusha, it's Yahuah.
For they will all know me
from the least of them to the greatest
of them, declares Yahuah.
For I will forgive their iniquity and
their sin I'll remember no more. Now,
you guys are not going to deny this is
Yahuah, right? Whom you say is the
father? Correct. Okay.
Jeremiah 30 I'm sorry. Hebrews 10:15-17.
Pay attention carefully.
And the holy spirit also testifies to us
for after saying After saying, "This is
the covenant that I will make with them
after this those days," says Yahuah cuz
the word here Lord is Yahuah.
Who's speaking?
It says Yahuah.
Yeah.
Oh, so you just admit that the Ruach is
Yahuah cuz he's the one who said these
words.
Yeah, it comes from him and if it's his
spirit then yes, it would be. doesn't
make that distinction. Don't Don't add
to the text. It doesn't need to make
that distinction.
What we read here Yahuah spoke these
words. But then
Yes. Hebrews says that was the spirit
cuz he is Yahuah who spoke.
It's right there, buddy.
So can I ask you a question then? Before
we get Yes, don't change the subject.
I'm trying to answer. I'm not changing
subject. I want to deal specifically
with those two verses. Do you First deal
with this. Explain What are you going to
do with this?
I'm I'm getting ready to explain it, but
I was going to ask you a question, but
I'll just explain it instead. Okay. So
if the spirit is coming from the father
to relay a message
and it comes with the message of this is
what I'm saying,
right? It is the spirit bringing the
message. It is also Yahuah bringing the
message. So it's not a problem for
Jeremiah to say this is coming from
Yahuah, the father, and then Hebrews to
say this is coming from the spirit. We
also see that happen multiple times with
the son where in the Old Testament it
says Yahuah is going to do something and
then in the New Testament it says
Yahusha is going to
jumping ahead because that actually
destroys you cuz it shows that Jesus is
Yahuah, but
Let me
Well, no, I'm saying that to say that
there was an understanding at that time
already that if you have the father and
then you have someone an agent like the
Ruach or the son or the word
No, that's not what I'm saying. Stop the
father. You can easily change them out.
They had that understanding. Stop
distorting agency. That's not what
agency meant. I have the documentation
from even Jewish sources.
Stop jumping the
I do as well and I can go to the Dead
Sea Scrolls and show you other places
where they
want me to show you that from the
rabbinic sources that they identify the
spirit as someone distinct from god
speaking to god?
That's fine cuz I also have rabbinic and
targumic sources that show that they
understood that.
The targum sources don't help you. They
actually prove the trinity. Take it
easy. I'll take you there.
Do you want me to go to targums now or
do you want to run from this because I'm
burying We We can
Let's stay here with I'll let you
decide. Do you want to go to the targums
or do you want to stay here? Let's Well,
believe me, I'm going to bury you with
the Aramaic targum Neofiti. Just be
patient.
I'm perfectly Let's deal with this, tap
dancer.
I'm not tap dancing. I answer your
question.
You just don't like the answer.
Talk over him one more time and I'm
going to send you to Harlem.
Okay. I'm sorry, what? The way you dealt
with this The way you dealt with this
was you acknowledge Yahweh speaks. But
now when it says the spirit says, "Oh,
that's simply the spirit
communicating what Yahweh said." That's
not what the text says. It says it's the
spirit who said these words.
He said, "This is the covenant that I
will make with them. After those days,"
it says the Lord, "I will put my laws
upon their heart and on their mind I
will write them." He then says, "And
their sins and their lawless deeds I'll
remember no more." The author did not
say the spirit relayed what Yahweh said.
He goes, "No, that's the spirit saying
these words in reference to himself."
May I address what you said?
May I address what you just said? Uh
hopefully. You want to tap dance?
Uh the first thing is because you're
coming presupposing certain things, you
assume that you need to see
Hold on. You're presuming that you need
to see a distinction made between the
father the father and the Ruach giving a
message. So you're saying Hold on. Hold
on. You asked me not to cut you off.
No, I'm not I'm not You're not here to
preach. You're here to engage me. You
just admitted there's But but you just
asked me not to cut you off, right? Are
the rules different for me than for you?
Yeah, very much so. Okay, have a good
day.
Yeah, run. Okay, run.
You You can You can stay here. Run, run,
Forest, run.
Okay, you want to stick around cuz your
buddy couldn't handle it. No, that's
fine. I'm staying around. Okay. So now
forget the tap dancer that couldn't help
you.
He admitted the spirit is distinct from
the father when I quoted this because
when I asked him, "When the spirit
will speak what he hears, who does he
hear from?" He said it's the father. So
you guys admitted the distinction.
The spirit hears from the father and he
will speak.
So that means you're admitting there's a
distinction. So why was he making that
point?
That there's a distinction?
He was trying to argue that I'm assuming
the distinction when he actually granted
that distinction.
Well, I don't think you allowed him to
finish what he was trying to say.
You finish it for him. Well, I I can't
finish it for him. Tell me your
position.
So okay, so what's what is the question?
I So just for clarification purposes,
reset. What's the question?
Okay, the question that your friend the
tap dancer tried to avoid
was the fact that in Jeremiah 31 the one
speaking is Yahweh, Yahuah.
Right?
Yes, that's what it says right there in
Jeremiah. But then here Hebrews says
that's the spirit speaking. He is
saying, "This is the covenant I will
make with them after those days as says
the Lord. I will put my laws upon their
heart and on their mind I will write
them. And their sins and their lawless
deeds I'll remember no more." Is that
saying the spirit communicated what
Yahweh said? No, it's saying the spirit
said this of himself. He is saying,
"This is the covenant I will make with
them."
Okay.
So, would in terms of the the testifying
aspect, would it be more of a witness or
actually saying?
Where it says the spirit testifies
because usually when someone is
testifying, yes, that is a witness or an
accomplice to something that has
happened and they are
says the Holy Spirit said it, brother.
What is it after saying?
testifies to us. Okay, now what does he
testify? Oh, my brother. Yeah, because
all all I'm ask all I'm asking is that
in terms of testifying because it is a
witness that is there.
Now, brother, really quick. Do you do
you see verse 15 where it says, "The
Holy Spirit also testifies to us
for after saying"? Did it say after
saying? The Holy Spirit is saying so,
right?
Did it say the Holy Spirit is saying?
It's just talking about for after
saying. Go join your friend. He's
waiting for you in Harlem. Go join him.
I'm telling he's asking the same
Your friend is waiting for you in
Harlem. Say hi. Bye-bye.
Oh, man. This is what happens when you
reject the Trinity, ladies and
gentlemen. You're going to make me more
disliked, buddy. And you put down my
screen again. Anyway, anyone
Why is it we talk about the fathers?
Uno, stop lying because the sherr are
looking for your mommy. Come up, Uno, so
I can make you dos.
And then tres. Anyway, now why is it
we're talking about
fathers, you guys want to go to the
Bible. But when he was debating New
Testament, they ran to the fathers.
Anyone on the fathers, dude?
I don't know. I'm trying to bring them
up, man, but
they all want to go to the Bible, man.
They don't want to talk about the early
church.